back in the second season of my show
I gave los angeles-based realtor sue
Stanford the idea of capitalizing on the
50% of people who believe in ghosts by
specializing in the sale of ghost free
homes it's really a wild idea so after
giving her marketing a complete overhaul
oh my gosh that's amazing I paired her
up with professional psychic Ron bard to
help her detect any ghosts that might be
lurking in her properties definitely I
feel like Jill's going down my spine
right is it a ghost no what I never saw
coming was that sue herself had had
intimate encounters with spirits in her
past it's like you know that Incubus is
there's a ghost I'll have sex with
someone until they die wow that's like
what I experienced when I was in
Switzerland what happened in Switzerland
when I was being choked yeah why earlier
we were shocked by what by an auntie
like that I felt like I was being like
the ghost choked you and Switzerland
yes Wow the filming of the ghost realtor
episode turned out to be an intense
personal experience for Sue come out
come out he was spirits come he must
messing up with the vertebras in the
neck leave now
leave now but with so many distractions
it was hard to tell at the time what she
really thought of my idea are you okay
yes actually I'm fine I think I'm
feeling a little relieved now it's
amazing it's been three years since I
rebranded sue as the ghost realtor and
when I recently checked out her website
I was delighted to discover that she'd
not only continued to use my idea in her
real estate practice but had gone as far
as teaming up with bran bard the psychic
and a small-time production company to
create a television pilot for a ghost
realtor reality series that she was
pitching around town
kind of money in here this is this is
not good I was so proud of how far
Seward run with my idea
how are you so when I gave her a call to
schedule a follow-up she shared some sad
news
[Music]
oh I'm sorry so but she told me she was
now working with a new psychic and she
wanted me to come meet him so it Sue's
insistence I paid her a visit at her
home tonight
yes sir yeah so I'm what's known as a
psychic medium but I'm also Claire
sentient which means that I feel my
angels I'm also clairvoyant which means
I can see I'm also clairaudient which is
most the time I actually hear I hear
voices and I also do financial advising
okay that's you utilize in spirit with
everything sue told me she was still
working hard to get the ghost realtor
show off the ground and she even hoped
that Ron could still be a part of it you
probably can help us from the other side
all yes definitely mm-hmm that's a great
point yeah you're on when we need some
help so you can talk to Ron even though
he's gone you can still sure and you
know I could do it I could try
communicate with Ron right now if y'all
like mm-hmm
right now sure why not
so do my the father-god are great for my
just for this vortex for this space for
this time great foam live just for all
of the angelic beings that are in this
home and as we evoke the spirit of wrong
we are grateful that su myself and
Nathan as a collective consciousness
that we are open and available intact go
ahead go ahead
do you want to ask a question for Ron
yes
[Music]
did he enjoy his experience on the show
yes great are there any more questions
that you that you have I guess how does
he feel about you replacing him
mmm he says it's good he says he knows
he says that I've got a good heart and
so he says it's good it's good do you
have any other questions Nathan I know
on the show he mentioned that he worked
on the OJ trial
hojae's defense team worked on OJ's case
yeah so do you think he's innocent he
was definitely innocent okay now that
he's on the other side does he have any
clearer info on maybe who the real
killer was he does but I don't I'm not
getting a name or anything like that
right now he knows who the killer is
yeah date yes
was it Oh Jay this is not coming from
wrong this is coming from me and that
answer is yes but Ron's not telling you
that every time I present him with that
he steps back
who's telling you then my own connection
with with my own with my own spirit
guides okay cool
that's how it works bye sue hi honey you
take care okay what thanks for coming by
so it only for women it was great to see
that Sue and her new psychic got along
so well and even though it was sad that
Ron had died I was happy he'd still be
able to guide them from the other side